for what value of C is X minus 3 a
factor of the polynomial P of X and they
tell us that P of X is negative x to the
third power plus CX squared minus 4x
plus 3 so I encourage you to now pause
this video and try to figure this out on
your own
so the the remainder theorem tells us
that if X minus 3 is a factor is a
factor of P of X and that's another way
of saying that P of X could be written
as that P of X could be written as X
minus 3 times something else this is
true if and only if if and only if P of
3 P of 3 is equal to 0 P of 3 let me
write P in it maybe yellow color this is
true if and only if P of 3 is equal to
is equal to 0 and this makes complete
sense because if you put 3 if you
evaluate P of 3 we're saying that X
minus 3 is a factor of P of X that means
that you could write P of X like this so
if you could write P of X like this what
would P of 3 be well you substitute a 3
right over you're gonna have 3 minus 3
for this expression that's just going to
be 0 times something else anything times
0 is 0 so this should make just just a
lot of common sense so P of 3 needs to
be equal to 0 so let's just evaluate P
of 3 and then figure out what C needs to
be in order to make P of 3 equal to 0 so
let's write this down so P of I'll do
the 3 in green P F 3 is going to be
equal to negative 3 an all-in-one color
actually negative 3 to the third power
plus C times 3 squared minus 4 times 3
plus 3 so what's this going to be equal
to this is going to be equal to negative
27 plus 9 C minus 12
three so what does that equal to let's
see this is negative twelve plus three
is negative nine plus negative
twenty-seven is negative 36 so this is
going to be 9c minus 36 and we remember
we want P of three to be equal to zero
this is P of three so we want this thing
right over here to be equal to zero so
let me make this clear we have P of
three is equal to this and we want to
set this to be equal to zero
so let's just solve this equation right
over here so you add 36 to both sides
you get 9c is equal to 36 divide both
sides by nine you get C is equal to four
so if C is equal to four if this if P of
X if P of X were to be equal to negative
x to the third plus four x squared minus
four X plus 3 then X minus three is a
factor of P of X